les peines sont tombés donc un stage de
citoyenneté pour l'un de tes agresseurs
et 35 heures de travail d'intérêt
général pour l'autre avant d'avoir ta
réaction Yanis que sur c'est vraiment ce
qui nous intéresse le plus j'aimerais
avoir la vie de Fabrice division
l'avocat qui Fabrice qui m'a écrit un
mot je n'avais pas vu encore voilà et
c'est toi qui m'a mis au courant de des
peines en fait cette affaire elle est
stupéfiante parce que le seul débat qui
se posait les deux est-ce que les faits
ont été commis la réponse est oui il y a
pas de débat et est-ce qu'il y avait un
caractère homophobe et on pouvait
débattre de ça et apparemment il y a pas
eu de débat le juge a considérer le
tribunal a considérer qu'il y avait bien
un caractère homophobe donc il y a bien
une circonstance aggravante et à la fin
de la fin on a une agression aggravée
par le caractère homosexuel et on se
retrouve avec une peine qui est
absolument
Fabrice c'est ça qui ont envie de savoir
de téléspectateurs et ici le public et
les chroniqueurs donc
en fait tout a été retenu absolument
contre les agresseurs a absolument donc
à un moment toi qui avocat tu t'es dit
quelle va être la peine en cours la
peine moi j'étais parti du principe si
tu veux très clairement une fois qu'on
est sorti de l'audience que la
culpabilité a été reconnue qu'on nous a
dit oui il y a pas de débat il y a bien
agression homosexuelle il dit bon ben ok
on va aller vers une peine
d'emprisonnement avec sursis l'idée est
pas d'hypothéquer l'avenir de ces jeunes
mais de leur faire comprendre qu'à un
moment donné il y a des choses qui ne se
font pas parce que il faut quand même
que le public sache qu'est-ce que c'est
un sage d'un stage de citoyenneté ça
c'est quoi bah en fait à Évry dans le
ressort de Ivry c'est aller au Mémorial
de la Shoah pour une petite visite et
aller voir finalement la déportation des
homosexuels et pour aider à prendre
conscience je veux dire pourquoi et donc
ça c'est juste une journée comme ça oui
bien sûr et après terminé avec une
question qu'on peut raisonnablement se
poser c'est finalement c'était quoi il y
avait quoi en dessous parce que au fond
on a retenu une agression à caractère
homophobe est-ce qu'on peut faire plus
faible qu'en peine c'est pas possible
tout a été retenu mais la peine est
absolument stupéfiant c'est que le
parquet est pas encore fait appel moi
j'ai pas le pouvoir de faire appel je ne
peux faire appel que sois intérêts civil
mais sur la peine c'est le parquet qui
peut faire appel on s'attendait à
communiquer de presse indigné du parquet
qui fasse appel j'arrive même pas les
avoir il répond tu au téléphone
maintenant il me répond plus donc il y a
un embarras si tu veux dans cette
affaire quel est leur intérêt mais leur
intérêt c'est parce qu'on est face à un
problème d'idéologie des mineurs c'est
qu'on considère que le mineur n'est pas
accessible à la peine or attention les
mineurs ici ils avaient 17 ans quand
même hein on n'est pas sur des mineurs
de 12 ans quand même et donc l'objectif
encore une fois si tu veux n'est
absolument pas d'hypothéquer l'avenir de
ces jeunes mais la peine on oublie
souvent que elle est là pour protéger la
société protéger la victime mais aussi
protéger l'agresseur pour lui permettre
de comprendre qu'il est allé trop loin
et qu'à un moment donné bah si il
continue comme ça il va se désocialiser
tout seul ici c'est le moment où il
fallait dire les choses quand tu as eu
le verdict Fabrice tu t'es dit quoi mais
ce que je me suis dit c'est il y a
forcément une erreur quelque part on
peut pas avoir tout retenu et venir
effectivement ensuite avoir un stage
citoyenneté 35 heures de tige dire c'est
pas possible et en fait ensuite et bah
finalement on s'est rendu compte que
c'était juste parce que c'était un
tribunal pour enfants et qu'ils ont été
jugés comme des enfants en fait et que
donc la notion de pencher l'enfant et
pas quelque chose qui est accessible
alors on va avoir le témoignage de notre
pianiste d'amour dans un instant juste
est-ce qu'il y a une personne ici autour
de la table qui comprend la légèreté de
cette peine Gilles oui voilà
sensibilisation éducation voilà les
attendus du jugement c'est à dire que le
effectivement le tribunal pour enfants
n'a pas voulu emprisonner mais même avec
sursis en disant il faut les éduquer il
faut les sensibiliser moi je trouve qu'à
cet âge-là alors bon ce qui choque c'est
que là il y en a un qui avait 18 ans il
faut rappeler il était mineur au moment
des faits
absolument mais pour moi ces gens-là les
envoyer en prison ou les condamnés un
peu de prison avec sursis ça ne change
rien il faut que ces gens-là changent
c'est pour qui change il faut les
éduquer les sensibiliser donc
mais moi je ne suis pas absolument
choqué alors alors on va on va en parler
dans un instant avec Jean juste Yanis
j'aimerais pour noter les spectateurs
qui nous est regardent ce soir est-ce
que tu peux nous rappeler l'affaire
l'histoire ce qui s'était passé
donc c'était c'était il y a quelques
temps maintenant c'était le 30 septembre
2021 exactement il y a moins d'un an
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est une
journée comme les autres à part que ben
j'ai décidé d'aller voir des amis à moi
une amie à moi donc on peut vendre dans
la vidéo ou à me protège avec le jean
bleu en tout en haut
et donc ensuite
je voulais la voir et en allant la voir
ben j'avais une envie de soif du coup je
vais dans une épicerie et quand il
chante d'épicerie ben je me fais déjà
interpellé par le groupe de jeunes avec
tout de suite avec des insultes monstres
directs d'un coup ça le [ __ ] tout ça je me
suis fait frapper par derrière à
plusieurs reprises j'ai fait 500 mètres
de marche je me suis ressais frappé j'ai
encore voulu repartir je me sens encore
refait frappé j'avais l'impression que
ça tourne en boucle ça tourne en boucle
j'allais jamais m'en sortir mais quand
on voit les images là on va parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils ont mis quand vous
voyez mais vous dites ça aurait pu être
beaucoup plus grave mais bien sûr c'est
ça qui est incroyable
c'est que là vous la vidéo que vous
voyez c'est la troisième scène c'est ça
incroyable Cyril c'est ça c'est qu'en
fait je comprends parfaitement le
positionnement de Gilles sur le sur le
la question de l'éducation mais à un
moment il y a une telle violence en fait
dans cette scène au regard en plus du
caractère homosexuel et puis il y a un
décalage on peut pas d'un côté vouloir
une protection des minorités et de
l'autre effectivement dire bon ben ce
que vous avez fait c'est une incivilité
non ne pas laisser sa place à une
vieille dame dans un bus c'est une
incivilité frapper quelqu'un en bande
organisé comme c'est fait là en raison
du caractère homosexuel c'est un délire
il y a pas mal de gens qui se posent la
question Fabrice division avant que
j'interroge vraiment Yanis et qui ne
disent qu'il ressent
beaucoup de gens qui s'interrogent qui
disent pourquoi il y en a que deux qui
ont été jugés
reste en cours pour les autres il y en a
beaucoup mais c'est pas évident pour le
coup la police judiciaire a fait un vrai
travail moi j'étais en contact avec eux
ils ont fait un vrai boulot et le
problème c'est qu'il y a aussi une loi
du silence dans les cités qui fait que
les deux qui ont été interpellés ça
ressort des procès-verbaux bah pas voulu
balancer et après on a des moyens qui
sont limités quoi d'accord alors Yanis
tu avais été extrêmement choqué tu étais
je me rappelle d'ailleurs c'est peu de
temps avec nous parce que c'était ça
t'avait mis le moral à zéro en plus de
d'avoir été touché physiquement tu avais
été très très fragilisé moralement par
par cette agression
tu attendais beaucoup de ce pro c'est
toi énormément vraiment vraiment
j'ai mis toute mon énergie dans cette
affaire là tu as pu voir tes agresseurs
revoir tes agresseurs pendant le je suis
pas par chaud aujourd'hui je mens parce
que j'avais pas dormi de la baie j'étais
vraiment stressé j'avais pas voulu genre
là vraiment avec impatience et ben le
lendemain ma mère elle m'a dit que
j'allais pas que ça allait partir pour
moi et voilà alors est-ce qu'ils ont
exprimé des regrets à ton égard lors du
procès de ce que tu as entendu ma mère
ne ment pas parler du coup Fabrice aucun
non
la négation des faits non c'est pas nous
c'est pas nous c'est pas nous
bah
on s'est rendu compte que c'était au CPE
quoi je veux dire et puis après c'est
oui mais bon
c'est pas il a un peu cherché mais
c'était pas loin quoi dire oui mais bon
ça c'est quelqu'un de particulier alors
ça veut dire quoi particuliers
et donc là encore une fois j'insiste sur
un poste judiciaire a fait un travail
assez exceptionnel pour les aider à
faire prendre conscience mais ça va
marcher il y a il y a ça marche quoi
alors Yanis donc comment tu as appris
c'est ta maman ma mère direct
35 heures de machin et oui et donc un
stage de citoyenneté qu'est-ce que tu as
dit mais j'étais en pleurs je me sens
embrouillé avec je comprenais pas je me
suis dit pourquoi en fait là les preuves
elles sont là je me suis fait agresser
je peux pas mentir l'épreuve ils sont là
maintenant ce que je comprends pas c'est
que pourquoi il n'y a pas eu de vrais
sanctions comment un agresseur peut
comprendre son sa bêtise en ayant ce
genre de sanction et puis surtout c'est
pour la suite c'est-à-dire que derrière
quel exemple derrière tout le monde va
dire ouais c'est pas grave
bah bien sûr et puis il faut pas oublier
une chose aussi Cyril c'est que
rappelez-vous les uns et les autres on
avait dit ici que Yanis était
suffisamment traumatisé pour que ils ne
puisse même plus sortir moi je
l'accompagnais Yannick jusque chez lui
je suis allé voir dans quelles
conditions il vivait et effectivement
j'ai mieux compris l'environnement en
fait il ne peut pas faire un pas sans
que les agresseurs lui tombent dessus
potentiellement donc il a du songer à
déménager et à un moment donné on
s'interroge quand même c'est lui la
victime et c'est lui qui doit partir il
y a un truc qui avait une unité
supérieure à 8 jours en plus alors il y
a nice justement tu en es où là
aujourd'hui tu habites où chez mes
parents toujours je suis domicile chez
mes parents toujours au même endroit
donc mais pas à Montgeron d'accord
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe pour toi
vraiment c'est à dire j'ai de la je
m'occupe plus de mes parents parce qu'il
y a la santé de mon père je sais ouais
qui est vraiment ça me fait trop mal au
cœur
j'ai mon père qui en soit pas
de vie ça veut dire c'est à faire là
ça me fait chier mais je m'en fous un
peu je préfère m'occuper de mes parents
mais d'un côté je peux pas parce que ben
je peux pas laisser ce genre de choses
pas c'est moi c'est à faire là j'irai
jusqu'au bout mon père il m'a dit va
jusqu'au bout mon fils va jusqu'au bout
et je vais jusqu'au bout jusqu'à le
dernier jour mon père il va quitter
cette terre là je vais aller jusqu'au
bout de cette affaire je peux le faire
l'honneur je vais faire cette honneur
mon père c'est dommage
quand tu dis tu vas aller jusqu'au bout
c'est quoi tu vas faire appel de la
décision et tu veux moi je peux pas
faire appel moi
et donc aujourd'hui bonjour Aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que peut faire
Yanis quand tu dis j'ai l'impression
d'être pris pour un couillon donc moi je
me fais frapper gratuitement je me vends
insulter mon image là de partout c'est
vrai et au final ça apporte pas assez de
fruits je comprends regarde c'est
incroyable mais c'est surtout que il y a
quelque chose qui n'a pas c'est que
maintenant on peut essayer de se
demander autre chose raisonnablement
c'est si ça avait été les enfants des
magistrats qui ont rendu à décision
est-ce que décision aurait été la même
on se raisonnablement se la poser cette
question parce que et c'est là où j'ai
un problème c'est qu'au fond Yanis son
image a circulé partout on a donc
revendiqué l'acte dans le mettant en le
publiant sur les réseaux sociaux on l'a
dit il y a aussi un autre paramètre sur
le plan familial moi j'ai rencontré ses
parents qui s'envolent de pas avoir su
le protéger bien on a tout un schéma
familial qui a été brisé mais en plus
il a été touché
il y a pas du tout de
aucune sanction contre ces gens on
considère que ce qui a été dit là est
une mesure éducative mais pour répondre
à Gilles sur ce point moi je suis pas
hostile à la mesure éducative mais tu
peux aussi imaginer qu'on peut aller
gradation dans les mesures éducatives il
puisse y avoir effectivement en mesure
ils sont un peu plus gradur graduels
alors Daniel tu peux croire que avec ces
images qu'on a vu il va tout d'un coup
le petit jeune qui a deux qui a deux
jours de citoyenne de stage de
citoyenneté va devenir un enfant de cœur
mais qui peut croire ça mais je voudrais
voir les personnes qui ont fait ce
jugement je voudrais
parce que l'éducation d'accord Gilles
quand tu défends ça je comprends même
pas comment tu fais et le mot éducation
c'est très bien évidemment que si on les
met en prison on protège la société mais
eux ils vont peut-être faire d'autres
mauvaises rencontres et tout ça mais
éducation c'est centre éducatif pendant
un an vu ce qu'ils ont fait ils étaient
aujourd'hui ils se sont acharnés
aujourd'hui vous rendez compte dans quel
état il y a nice il se dit ouais
c'est ça
c'est
sûr négligeable comment j'ai une
question mais comment vous voulez qu'on
fasse des démarches pour faire des
démarches pour qu'il y a une justice
c'est la justice ne fait pas son travail
mais je vais te dire autre chose moi toi
tu as voulu l'histoire elle a été
énormément médiatisée ça veut dire que
tout le monde est au courant il y a le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui était au
courant toi tu t'es venu en parler ici
tu imagines les les autres qui sont
agresser ou qui vont se faire agressif
ils vont dire mais moi j'ai pas envie
d'être comme yanismes j'ai pas envie et
de me retrouver un an après avec un
jugement où ils vont rien prendre du
tout et je vais je vais tout le monde
aura vu ma tête mine de rien mais même
en terme d'exemplarité c'est
catastrophique un signal catastrophique
signal qu'on envoie c'est quand même un
signal d'impunité et puis si tu veux
j'ai un autre problème avec ça c'est
qu'au fond ça fait le jeu qui est pas le
mien de ceux qui réclament toujours plus
de fermeté toujours plus bien sûr et pas
le mien pour le coup moi je suis pour la
proportionnalité des peines dans un sens
comme dans l'autre je ne veux pas qu'un
type qui vole une feuille ce qu'on a 10
ans de prison je veux pas que c'est ces
types avec 10 ans en prison mais je veux
pas non plus à l'inverse qu'on est
effectivement une punch qui ne qui ne
soit pas adaptée au fait ici je le
redonne s'ils avaient finalement ne pas
laisser leur place on parle d'incivilité
enfin un moment donné il faut appeler un
chat un chat un civilisé
on n'en peux plus en fait de ça on en
peut plus du laxisme le sentiment
d'impunité moi je repense au tweet de
Linar du maire de Cannes il a dit quand
elle a été agressée moi finalement je
vais faire justice moi-même mais en fait
on en peut plus parce que les citoyens
vont vouloir faire juste eux-mêmes parce
que vos parents en fait ils doivent être
mais dégoûtés mais c'est insupportable
donc la justice excusez-moi elle est pas
au rendez-vous la justice elle est nulle
et il y a un problème face à leur
sauvagement pourquoi elle doit changer
on doit s'adapter parce qu'aujourd'hui
la violence déjà n'est beaucoup trop
forte et on peut pas donner des stages
de citoyenneté qui soit qui sont
prétextes qui sont gadgets parce que
c'est insupportable mais je vais vous
dire alors on peut pas se faire justice
soi-même comme vous l'avez dit bien sûr
non non je sais mais ce qui va arriver
les gens vont dire les gens vont se dire
bah tu vois là derrière face à ce
laxisme en fait c'est laxiste comment va
faire en fait mais c'est exactement ça
parce que ce qui caractérise l'état de
droit c'est la capacité qu'on a à
pouvoir compter sur la justice comme
seul violence légitime c'est à dire
qu'au fond c'est elle qui répare les
torts pour qu'on n'est pas à le faire
nous-mêmes mais si elle le fait plus
dans cette dans ce cas-là c'est flagrant
si on me dit parce que on parle de
l'excuse de minorité mais lui aussi
j'étais mineur
qui vont en tant qu'avocat parce
qu'aujourd'hui la justice moi on entend
on dit toujours cette phrase je
comprends la justice etc est-ce que vous
y croyez encore alors d'abord c'est la
justice elle incarnée par des hommes
c'est ça chaque Guitry qui disait la
justice j'ai jamais déjeuner avec c'est
un peu ça l'idée la justice elle est
incarnée par des hommes avec leur limite
et leur faiblesse il y a deux éléments
quand même c'est que ici on a aussi un
jugement qui est un peu dans l'air du
temps de l'idéologie c'est à dire qu'au
fond dès qu'on a affaire un mineur on
est dépassé en fait et et en fait je
pense qu'on a un problème en considérant
que eminemer celui qui a moins de 18 ans
et mettre quelqu'un de 12 ans ou 17 ans
c'est quand même pas la même chose on
peut pas dire que les juges alors on mal
fait leur travail c'est que c'est les
lois existantes
correspond pas à l'époque mais eux ils
ont fait leur boulot oui mais je me
méfie alors je vais te dire un truc
Cyril je me mets je me méfie autant des
changements de loi parce que finalement
quand les changements de loi sont faits
sous la pression populaire il y a un
risque de de sens inverse il ne faudrait
quand même pas oublier cette affaire est
terrifiante elle est terrible mais je
serai quand même pas oublier qu'on a
affaire à des mineurs quand même et que
le premier vertu de la justice des
mineurs ça reste quand même de permettre
à un mineur de comprendre que quand il
va être majeur cette fois-ci on va moins
rire parce que là qu'est-ce qui va se
passer qu'est-ce qui serait passé si on
était six mois après il y a 17 ans et
quelques ils sont ils sont jugés les
fesses se déroulent à 18 ans les
horaires quoi ils ont eu peut-être pas
ils ont probablement faire d'accord
le but bien sûr mais le but
effectivement c'est quand même un moment
donné de permettre à la société de dire
à ces mineurs attends la terre elle est
vraiment trop loin mais ça peut pour
cette fois ok bon bon mais quand même on
va condamner cet acte pour que tu
comprennes que c'est toi que tu es
vraiment allé trop loin pour pas que
ensuite tu te retrouves en prison quoi
ça marche pas parce que les autres ils
disent même pas qu'ils étaient Yanis
est-ce que est-ce que toi aujourd'hui tu
aurais aimé aussi voilà on parle plus de
justice là qui viennent te voir qui te
disent voilà on a on a déconné on
s'excuse on me demande pardon parce que
voilà moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] qui
vient de me s'excuser à moi juste auprès
de mes parents
je prenne ma famille en fait moi je m'en
fous parce que ce qui est fait si on
peut plus revenir en arrière maintenant
ce qu'il faut ce que moi je peux faire
c'est d'avancer de me relever et voilà
mais moi moi je vais vous dire Fabrice
en vrai voilà sage de citoyenneté 35
heures j'aurais préféré à la limite
qu'ils disent vous allez aller voir les
parents de Yanis vous allez voir Yanis
travailler dans une association stop
homophobie
voilà vous avez même qui est qui aille
voir ses parents qui s'excuse qui disent
voilà c'est parce qu'il nous a je sais
pas voilà mais là à quoi ça sert parce
qu'en fait ils verront jamais lianisme
à quoi ça sert tu pourrais aller plus
loin c'est que 35 heures de tiges
pourquoi 35 pourquoi pas 40 pourquoi pas
20 ça rime à quoi en fait et puis
finalement le petit j'ai pas déterminé
et puis ce stage citoyenneté ok mais
allez allez voir effectivement
maintenant elle doit la Shoah pendant
une heure la déportation elles
homosexuels parce que tu penses qu'ils
vont faire le lien non mais juste
question sur les stages de citoyenneté
j'ai regardé la loi quand même qui était
adopté en 2002 et les stages de
citoyenneté ne doivent concerner que les
outrages rebellion les injures racistes
les vols les escroqueries les
dégradations et les dénonciations
mensongères les infractions que du
travail elles sont où les agressions à
caractère parce que on considère que
pour les mineurs il y a l'extension
en fait fait divers après faits divers
on se rend compte que la justice
française c'est vraiment une aberration
et moi quand je vois le mot stage de
citoyenneté pour moi c'est pas une
condamnation ça devrait être un devoir
c'est à dire que toutes les personnes
qui va qui va à l'encontre de la
citoyenneté qu'il soit majeur ou mineur
devrait de toute façon avoir un stage de
citoyenneté et en plus une condamnation
parce que pour moi s'agit pas du tout
une condamnation ça normal que tu dois
parler à Yanis un peu parce que Yanis il
sait que je l'aime vraiment énormément
et que voilà c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
qu'on a eu avec nous ici qui est un
garçon incroyable qui on a eu on s'est
vraiment beaucoup attaché et c'est vrai
que Yanis aujourd'hui je se sent très
triste je sens vraiment en fait je suis
pas triche je suis juste peiné en fait
je comprends pas
tu te sens impuissant tu te sens
impuissant tu te dis c'est je peux rien
faire là j'ai tout fait mon maximum je
suis parti jusqu'au bout pour pour qu'il
y a une tu as fait tout ce que tu avais
dit de faire c'est ça en fait tu t'es
fait agresser tu as vécu des moments
extrêmement difficiles dans une famille
ou je peux dire voilà c'est pas facile
tous les jours la famille Yanis on sait
que son papa est extrêmement malade
et il doit s'en occuper on sait voilà
comment ça se passe chez lui il a tout
fait pour dire je vais aller au bout du
truc parce que c'est des moments
difficiles d'aller témoigner de raconter
l'histoire aussi de faire des télés de
médiatiser l'affaire et derrière tu te
dis moi j'ai tout fait bien et derrière
j'ai l'impression comme tu as dit tout à
l'heure qu'on te prend pour un couillon
c'est vrai
aujourd'hui pour toi c'est quoi c'est
c'est limite c'est une deuxième sanction
qui tombe dessus bon en fait j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme si on me
disait c'est bien fait pour toi vraiment
je me suis vraiment
la théorie de est-ce que tu l'as pas un
peu cherché c'est incroyable
c'est ça dans la tête parce que bien sûr
ce qui existe ça veut montrer mais c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que moi je vais un
peu plus loin et que du coup je vais
j'ai regardé sous la Hyères pour
demander une enquête administrative sur
les conditions à laquelle je mens était
rendu je veux dire je veux quand même
savoir ce qui s'est passé on peut pas
d'un côté retenir tous les faits et de
l'autre avoir quelque chose qui soit des
réservoir je peux je peux vous dire la
personne qui a pris la décision
et là il a jamais vu Yanis c'est ça
est-ce qu'il aurait pas envie même de
rencontrer moi je faisais que je prenne
dans comme ça j'ai envie quand même de
rencontrer le le
quand tu vois la vidéo tu dis pas c'est
pas en tant que juge moi ce serait juste
je me suis remis à la place de tout le
monde d'abord au côté de la victime puis
après aux côtés
en effet ils sont établis sur les faits
ils sont pas contestés ils sont établis
le juge le juge il a pas pu et on veut
il va vous dire quoi le juge il va dire
moi j'ai j'ai suivi quoi c'est c'est
parce que c'était des mineurs donc je
peux pas aller plus loin parce que la
loi c'est pas plus loin mais c'est ça
l'autorisation
pourquoi il a pas fait alors
ça c'est le mystique c'est ce qu'il faut
que l'enquête administrative détermine
c'est pour ça que administrative moi je
ne condamne personne je veux quand même
savoir parce que moi j'ai une crainte
derrière laquelle la crainte c'est bon
il a peut-être un peu cherché non mais
c'est pas possible
j'exerce ce métier tu es assez longtemps
pour savoir que ce qui est pas possible
finalement un au bout d'un moment on
serait surpris donc moi c'est pour ça
que je veux quand même savoir on a d'un
côté un prénom de la République à garde
des sceaux qui t'explique que les
mineurs maintenant faut quand même faire
attention à pas non plus avoir toujours
une excuse de minorité mais de l'autre
on a des magistrats qui suivent pas moi
je ne juge personne bon par quelqu'un
déjà 1 le parquet pourquoi il fait pas
appel il est important de la société moi
j'aurais attendu un communiqué de presse
au terme duquel il fait il fait appel
deuxièmement il faut quand même savoir
dans quelles conditions cette décision a
été rendue après tout on a des
précédents judiciaires dans la dans leur
histoire qui vont qui vous montre que
parfois bon je peux pas croire que le
parquet après avoir vu un méanis ce soir
on pleure ne fasse pas appelé c'est pas
possible
maximale qu'ils encourir en étant mineur
quelle était la peine maximale qu'ils en
courant déterminer ils pouvaient
encourir c'était pas c'était pas le
problème
75000 € d'amende alors Yanis aujourd'hui
question
aux institutions
à la justice au garde des sceaux qui est
peut-être nous regarde ce soir donc le
ministre de la Justice
Eric Dupond-Moretti puisque c'est le
seul à pouvoir saisir le parquet
aujourd'hui c'est lui le dit c'est en
tout cas si le lui dit le parquet de
fera si le lui dit pas bon voilà ouais
ben moi j'aimerais déjà que cette
affaire soit pas terminée comme ça ça se
fait vraiment pas
j'ai résisté j'avais pas mal de
blessures j'ai tout camouflé j'ai tout
j'ai fait un maximum pour être bien
j'arrive pas vraiment j'arrive pas cette
vidéo ne veut pas sortir de ma tête
c'est affaire ne peut pas se terminer
comme ça si il faut que je vais jusqu'au
bout ça va prendre 5 ans mais je vais
prendre ses 50 ma vie et je vais pas les
laisser comme ça les 10 mails je fais
les retrouver j'espère que la justice
que vous les retrouver je ne veux pas
qu'il y en a deux sur le groupe
j'espère moi j'espère deux choses
j'espère que toi tu vas aller mieux tu
vas pouvoir avancer et essayer aussi de
doubler cette histoire et avancer et
vivre sur ta vie et que franchement
c'est
trop simple de dire ça comme ça moi je
suis passé à la télé
me reconnaissent trop facilement trop
facilement les gens direct des fois je
peux tomber sur des couillons des fois
je peux tomber sur des gens très
bienveillant
c'est 55 ans vraiment
j'espère vraiment je te dis que tu vas
pouvoir te reconstruire parce qu'on
t'aime énormément tu es un garçon
formidable et aussi on espère aussi que
les les agresseurs vont peut-être un
moment prendre conscience aussi de du
mal qui lui ont fait du mal qui l'ont
fait et
en vidéo
aller sur n'importe qui
conscience en voyant le témoignage de
Yannis
en tout cas Yanis c'est qu'on t'aime
fort merci